[Music]
the beta release of ionic 4 was
announced yesterday and with it comes a
whole suite of new features that take
advantage of the best technologies that
we have available on the web in today's
video I'll show you some of the most
important changes if migrating from
version 3 to 4 but we'll also answer the
question should I use ionic because in
2018 there's a whole bunch of different
ways we can build and deliver apps and
you really need to know the trade-offs
between each strategy to make a good
business decision if you're new here
like and subscribe and if you're serious
about building apps consider becoming a
pro member at angular firebase comm so
should you use ionic to build your
mobile app to answer this question you
really need to understand your own
technical demands and weigh the pros and
cons of different mobile app development
approaches there are basically three
main ways that people are building
mobile apps today the first one we'll
look at is using the native SDKs
directly this means you write a separate
app for each platform that you want to
target in its native language for
Android that would be Kotlin or java in
iOS that means swift or Objective C and
on the web that means JavaScript
generally speaking the highest quality
best performing apps that you'll find
are built in their native SDKs but
there's a pretty obvious drawback here
and that's the cost more code to
maintain obviously means more operating
costs but you also have to hire the
right talent to be able to maintain
these code bases which is pretty hard to
do especially for iOS and Android this
brings me to the second strategy which
is where ionic 4 Falls and that's
building a hybrid mobile app using web
technologies the idea is to write your
code once and run it on multiple
platforms seamlessly and while that
sounds great it's not without its
trade-offs a hybrid app is really just a
web app that gets embedded on the native
device through a webview a hybrid app is
not able to communicate with a lot of
native device features directly so it
uses a bridge known as Apache Cordova or
capacitor that wrap native code in a
JavaScript API so it can be accessed by
the web app so the obvious benefit here
is that you can leverage web developers
to build mobile apps that are
cross-platform for a lot less money and
if done well it should be
indistinguishable from a truly native
app but because you've decoupled
yourself from the native SDKs they sort
of just become a black box then
debugging and performance optimization
become a little more difficult and the
third approach is to use a framework
like react native flutter or native
script to build your mobile app the
primary difference between ionic is that
these frameworks don't use a webview for
the UI they go about it in different
ways but that's the primary
distinguishing feature between these
frameworks and ionic and that can't
offer some advantages which I'll talk
about here in a minute so now let's look
at a couple real-world scenarios to
decide if ionic is a good fit or not
let's say you're the CTO of your company
and you need to decide if ionic is going
to be a good front-end for your software
as a service product in my opinion the
right decision really comes down to how
you're going to be delivering the app to
your customers let's say you're focusing
only on progressive web apps which are
now shipped in all major browsers in
this scenario ionic is going to be
mostly useful to you as a component
library when we get to the code we'll
see that an ionic 4 app looks very
similar to just a vanilla angular 6 CLI
app so the primary value-add of ionic
over just angular is that you have
access to these pre-built components and
services that help you solve common UI
use cases
another potential scenario is that your
primary product is a progressive web app
but your customers also want support for
iOS and Android apps this is the niche
where hybrid apps shine the brightest
if a PWA is your primary product you
really want to focus your resources on
optimizing that experience but ionic
makes it relatively easy to take that
existing code base and get it deployed
to the App Store and you can do it
without rippling your development cost
which is always worth considering that
brings us to the third scenario where
the mobile app is your primary product
and a progressive web app is more of
just an afterthought or non-existent at
all ionic 4 has hedged its bets on web
technology such as web components and it
really feels optimized for products that
are building progressive web apps you
can definitely use ionic 4 exclusively
building native mobile apps but there's
a few advantages to using non webview
frameworks that you should be aware of
the biggest advantage in my opinion is
that you can run purely native code
inside of frameworks like react native
and flutter this means that you can
overcome certain performance issues
because you're no longer using a bridge
you're actually just interacting
directly with native SDK code and
flutter doesn't use a bridge at all so
you're just more why
to get better performance right out of
the box another thing these frameworks
do is hot reloading which is different
than the live reloading that ionic does
hot reloading maintains the state of the
app while simultaneously updating any
changes to your code this might not
sound like a big deal but I found that
it makes the development process go
significantly faster when you're working
with native emulators and the third
advantage you'll notice is with testing
ionic does have some testing guidance in
version 4 which is based off the angular
CLI is implementation with Jasmin and
karma that's great for the web but with
react native and flutter you'll notice a
lot more resources dedicated to testing
on real mobile devices so those are the
main benefits of these frameworks but
they also have their drawbacks as well
for flutter you'll have the learning
curve of the dart programming language
which is pretty obscure and it's common
to hit performance bottlenecks with the
react native bridge so you may end up
writing more native code than you had
intended originally so the bottom line
is that you need to look at your own
situation and then weigh the pros and
cons of the various options that are out
there now that we know that let's go
ahead and jump into an ionic 4 app and
take a look at the actual developer
experience you will need to install
ionic globally with NPM and you'll want
to make sure that you have version 4.0
or greater installed one of the biggest
differences with ionic 4 is that instead
of using angular components it uses web
components which is made possible by a
really awesome library called stencil
which you should definitely check out if
you're into web components one of the
key benefits of this move is that ionic
4 is now framework agnostic meaning you
can use bjs angular react or just plain
JavaScript to build your apps but if
you're an angular developer you still
have first-class support for angular and
that's what I'm going to show you today
so we can run ionic start with the tabs
template and we'll set the type to
angular if you open up this project
you'll know that it looks very similar
to an angular 6 CLI project and that's
because it's using the angular 6 CLI
under the hood it adds a few extra
things here specifically for native
mobile apps such as that config.xml for
Cordova and in this resources file for
your native builds the CLI does have
some extra commands for building your
apps on native platforms but for the
most part it works just like the angular
CLI if you're migrating from ionic 3
you'll notice some changes to the
project directory structure all of the
app code is contained in the app
directory which follows
same pattern as you would see in a
typical angular app to migrate your code
over you could simply copy and paste it
into the app directory and there's a few
vs code plugins out there that will help
you rewrite all the paths in your app
perhaps the biggest change you'll notice
an ionic 4 is that it now uses the
angular router instead of ionic zone
pushpop kind of navigation system in my
opinion this is a really positive change
because the angular router is super
powerful and I've covered this in
previous videos you'll have better tools
in place for managing router state and
your end-users won't notice any changes
whatsoever let's take a closer look at
the router by generating a new page
component in ionic a page is just a
component but it will automatically be
wired up with your router for lazy
loading you'll notice that generates a
new directory called profile in the app
directory and if we go into the app
routing module you'll see that edit is
set up this component to be lazy loaded
to the profile path this is actually a
really nice feature
I kind of hate setting up lazy loading
manually so it's nice that the ionic
framework does this for you right out of
the box if we serve the app we can just
route directly to that profile path and
we'll see this component gets rendered
there yet another benefit of using the
angular router is that our paths are now
much easier for deep linking because
they're just a regular URL and not using
the hash location strategy which was the
case in ionic 3 there's a long list of
breaking changes with the way components
are set up but these are all pretty
minor breaking changes so it's not that
hard to migrate in my experience one
change you'll notice is that the ionic
button is now a custom element instead
of a directive and it still comes with
all the built-in mechanisms that you
would expect to control the shape color
and style of the button itself
navigating to different pages with a
button is easier than ever because we
can just use the router link directive
from angular and pass them the path that
we want to navigate to then if we go
into the component itself and click this
button you'll see that it navigates
between components but it also adds this
nice little animation between those
transitions so that's a nice little UI
feature to have implemented right out of
the gate and if you're worried about
breaking changes there is a detailed
dock on github that will break each one
of them down obviously we can't cover
them all here but they're really just
different naming convention
and everything will basically feel the
same from ionic three and another thing
you should be aware of is that it will
be possible to use capacitor plugins
instead of Cordova plugins in the future
I covered this in my 5 apps in five
minutes video so make sure to check that
out if you haven't seen it already
another minor but important change
you'll notice is that instead of
providers and ionic they're now called
services which again aligns with the
angular conventions so if you're
migrating over you'll likely want to
change your providers to services and
aside from the naming they work exactly
the same as they did previously and the
last thing you'll notice is that some of
the synchronous API zarnow asynchronous
api's we can show an example of this by
using the alert controller and we'll go
ahead and inject that in the constructor
in this component rendering these UI
elements happens in the context of a
promise now so we can use the async
await syntax which is really nice
aside from using async await everything
else looks pretty much exactly the same
and you could even convert these
promises to observables if you want to
do it and more of a reactive programming
style but basically all we're doing here
is writing a method that will be able to
show the user an alert message when a
button is clicked this is really common
functionality that you'll use all the
time and it's really nice to have a
framework that does this kind of stuff
for you
so should you use ionic 4 and in my
opinion the answer is yes assuming that
you have the right use case for a hybrid
app strategy I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you're
ready to build a production grade ionic
app consider becoming a pro member to
get access to my ionic native plus
firebase course thanks for watching and
I'll see you soon with more ionic 4
content